hello and good afternoon welcome to our
briefing today pathways to regenerative
agriculture farm policy for the 21st
century which is presented in
partnership with the natural resources
defense council i'm dan bersett
executive director of the environmental
and energy study institute
the environmental and energy study
institute was founded in 1984 on a
bipartisan basis by members of congress
to provide science-based information
about environmental energy and climate
change topics to policy makers
more recently we've also developed a
program to provide technical assistance
to rural utilities interested in on-bill
financing programs to help make energy
efficiency beneficial electrification
and renewable energy more accessible and
affordable for their customers
esi provides informative objective
non-partisan coverage of climate change
topics in briefings written materials
and on social media all of our
educational resources including briefing
recordings fact sheets issue briefs
articles newsletters and podcasts are
always available for free online at
www.eesi.org
if you'd like to make sure you always
receive our latest educational resources
just take a moment to subscribe to our
bi-weekly newsletter climate change
solutions
today is a departure from our two
companion briefing series living with
climate change and scaling up innovation
to drive down emissions which will
continue on june 24th with extreme heat
and june 29th with offshore wind energy
be sure to sign up for these briefings
and review the six previous installments
by visiting us online at www.esi.org
and there are two reasons for this
departure first along with our briefings
from a few months ago about financing
inclusive clean energy investments in
rural america and building a durable
national framework for large landscape
conservation our coverage of agriculture
and conservation topics is increasing to
match activity on capitol hill in the
lead-up to the 2023 farm bill
in addition to briefings regular readers
of our bi-weekly newsletter climate
change solutions already know that we
have been publishing articles about
climate and agriculture solutions like
cover crops no-till farming and
rotational grazing
and they also know about our
comprehensive farm bill 2023
congressional hearing tracker summarizes
highlights and takeaways from house and
senate committee and subcommittee
hearings in the coming months new
resources for policy makers will be
coming online
we know what it feels like to be a new
la or lc when that realization hits oh
the farm bill's happening and wait it's
how many pages i have how long to get up
to speed well don't worry esi will be
there for you to help you figure it out
and track your boss's priorities
and second and most importantly and this
is the one that explains today's topic
in particular
is that nrdc recently released a report
regenerative agriculture firm policy for
the 21st century a link to the report is
available on the webpage for our
briefing today at www.esi.org
this incredible report is based on
interviews with 113 farmers and ranchers
across 47 states in the district of
columbia about about what regenerative
agriculture means to them as well as why
and how they put certain practices to
use
this diversity of viewpoints is a major
strength of the report and those
viewpoints helped inform the policy
recommendations findings and case
studies outlined in the report to
illustrate the numerous benefits of
regenerative agriculture which is
defined as a land management philosophy
whereby farmers and ranchers grow food
and fiber and harmony with nature in
their communities all four of our
panelists today were involved in the
report
but before we turn it over to our
panelists let me remind everyone that we
will have some time for questions today
and we will do our best to incorporate
questions from our audience if you have
a question you can ask us two different
ways the first is you can send us an
email ask
at eesi.org that's ask eesi.org or even
better follow us on twitter online at
eesi online and send it to us by
responding to the live tweeting thread
and bonus points if you use the hashtag
eesitalk
we are joined today by a very special
guest
senator john tester is a third
generation montana farmer who was first
elected to represent his state in the
u.s senate in 2006. he is also a former
music teacher
school board member state senator and
president of the montana state senate he
is an outspoken voice for rural america
and an advocate for small business
owners and entrepreneurs
in the senate senator tester chairs the
veterans affairs committee and sits on
the commerce indian affairs banking and
appropriations committees senator tester
thank you so much for joining us today
hi this is senator john tester coming to
you from washington d.c and i want to
thank anna mcginn and matthew kaplan for
inviting me to speak to you all
and eesi and nrdc for co-hosting this
event today
i may be a u.s senator but in my real
life i'm a farmer and it's always great
to get together with my fellow farmers
and discuss the latest developments in
agriculture as a good friend of mine
once said there are about as many ways
to farm as there are farmers
regenerative ag is a critical piece of
the future of agriculture
it's good for the soil
and it's good for the climate
and therefore it's good for the crops we
raise which means it works pretty well
for producers
i'm glad to see you all gathering here
today to discuss the future of farming
and working to combat the climate crisis
that affected
rural communities across the treasure
state
i see the effects of warming
temperatures on my farm especially with
the lack of moisture in north central
montana my wife charlotte and i have
been running our farm in big sandy for
44 years
and last year was by far the worst
harvest we've ever had because of
extreme weather conditions
i know we're not alone family farms
across montana are hurting and when
producers suffer our rural economies
also suffer
we've done some good work for montana
producers by securing critical usda
disaster relief resources for farmers
affected by the drought and excessive
moisture and fires
but there is more to do to combat the
underlying causes of these disasters
regenerative agriculture is key to
pushing us in the right direction so
thanks again for having me and know that
you have my support
thank you senator tester for joining us
today to help us kick off this briefing
and thanks to your staff for also
helping to make your participation
possible
now let's turn to our panel and our
first panelist is aruhi sharma
aruhi is the deputy director of
regenerative agriculture at the natural
resources defense council she advocates
for policies that promote regenerative
agriculture to mitigate climate change
protect soil health conserve and reduce
water and restore biodiversity and she's
one of the lead authors of this report
regenerative agriculture farm policy for
the 21st century it is the subject for
our briefing today
welcome and congratulations on a
fantastic report i'm really looking
forward to hearing you tell me all about
it
great thank you so much um and yeah it
was a labor of love getting this report
over the finish line so i appreciate
that shout out
and thank you for your remarks senator
tester it's always an honor to partner
with you on issues related to
agriculture and climate change and you
are absolutely right you are not alone
in experiencing the disruptions of
climate change on your farm the growers
we spoke with across the country for
this report have been facing and are
facing similar challenges but more on
that a little bit later
hello everyone my name is aruhi sharma
and
like was mentioned earlier i'm the
deputy director of regenerative
agriculture for the natural resources
defense council nrdc for short
nrdc is an international environmental
nonprofit organization that works to
preserve and protect natural resources
people and communities
thanks to all of you for taking the time
to join our webinar this morning if
you're on pacific time like me or
afternoon
to discuss nrdc's recent report on
regenerative agriculture titled
regenerative agriculture farm policy for
the 21st century
for those who haven't had a chance to
read it through yet here's a quick
summary
so this side shows how my team and i
interviewed 113 farmers and ranchers
across the country to learn more about
regenerative agriculture from the folks
doing the work on the ground
with representation from 47 states and
the district of columbia we got a pretty
good lay of the land pun intended and
learned what regenerative agriculture is
its benefits and the barriers and
opportunities to bringing more acres
under regenerative management
a few notes about what we learned next
slide please
the first is that regenerative
agriculture is not new it has deep roots
in indigenous wisdom
tribal communities have been practicing
and managing lands regeneratively for
millennia
and now a growing number of farmers and
ranchers are leaning on this indigenous
knowledge to grow healthy food fight
climate change and build resiliency onto
the land
now a bunch of you are probably saying
okay great well what is regenerative
agriculture well next slide please
what we learned is that it is a land
management philosophy where farmers and
ranchers grow in harmony with nature
now there are five main principles that
underpin this regenerative philosophy
next slide
the first is nurturing relationships
within and around a farm
relationships between humans
land plants water pollinators predators
pests even soil microbes are the crux of
regenerative agriculture
so growers foster and protect those
relationships wherever and however they
can
the second principle is understanding
your social and environmental context
now regenerative growers made it a point
to learn about their unique farms
landscape the naturally available
resources on the land and the ecosystem
around the farm
they use what they learn to inform what
on-farm practices they should use and
are best used for their landscape for
example
if a farmer's farm is next to a river
the grower will plant trees or hedgerows
at the edge of the farm to prevent soil
erosion into the water body
while also providing shade and
sequestering carbon
another example if a grower knows that
water is becoming increasingly scarce in
their area like what we're experiencing
out here in the west
regenerative goers will transition to
planting crops that are not water
intensive to adapt to these new changes
the third principle is prioritizing soil
health
now we all know that soil is at the
heart of a healthy food system and
regenerative growers know that healthy
soup healthy soil grows healthy food
generally regenerative growers limit the
mechanical soil disturbance on the land
and they do so to protect the biological
structures that soil microbes bacteria
and fungi build in the soil
those same soil those same structures by
the way that help store carbon
the fourth principle is to reduce the
reliance on synthetic inputs
regenerative farmers and ranchers tried
to reduce their reliance on synthetic
inputs like herbicides pesticides and
chemical fertilizers
now most of our interviewees found that
while prioritizing soil health they
ended up needing fewer chemicals anyway
and of course fewer chemicals meant
beneficial insects and wildlife coming
back onto the land which helped
naturally reduce pest pressures
now this last principle the fifth one
nurturing relationships outside off the
farm we learned that relationships in
regenerative agriculture go beyond
on-farm practices to include
relationships with co-workers with
history with consumers and with
themselves and their communities
they encouraged customers to visit the
farm to see what they were doing first
hand
they had field days where families and
other farmers came to visit to learn
they paid their laborers of living wage
you know this fifth principle actually
captured some of the social and cultural
components of regenerative agriculture
that my team and i didn't expect to
learn through our interviews
now you see all of these laid out in
this wonderful honeycomb shape and
you'll know that you'll notice that each
of these principles builds on and
relates to one another for example by
prioritizing soil health you reduce the
use of synthetic inputs which helps
protect ecosystem relationships while
also contributing to the welfare of
surrounding communities so there's this
great synergy great symbiosis between
these these five principles
and because regenerative agriculture is
a management philosophy it looks
different across the country next slide
please
as a result
when we asked interviewees what
practices they used on the land they
shared a lot of different ones including
cover cropping no-till or low-till crop
diversity agroforestry composting dry
farming solar panels like there was a a
lovely hodgepodge of practices that
growers could choose from
but one thing was clear to continuously
improve the land
growers used multiple practices
and as growers continued on their
regenerative journey
they continued stacking practice on top
of practice and as a result they were
seeing faster land regeneration results
from improving water quality and water
retention on the land which is very
important considering drought conditions
and the swing from drought to extreme
weather
to sequestering more carbon and
improving biodiversity to keeping more
money in their pockets by not having to
spend much on inputs
to feeling more connected with their
consumers and their farming communities
the folks we interviewed shared a
multitude of ways that regenerative
agriculture benefited them and the land
next slide
if i could step back a little bit and
share personally what i found really
moving was the way that growers talked
about the mental health benefits of
regenerative agriculture
they enjoyed learning about the land
that they worked on and the animals that
they raised they felt free and empowered
to experiment and innovate on the land
and they shared how happy they were that
they were able to make management
decisions based on what they saw and
what they felt on the land instead of
being told what to do
okay so that's the first 17 pages
summarized for you
if there's one thing you take away from
all of that it's that regenerative goers
think of their land as ecosystems and
use practices that strengthen those
ecosystems like using cover crops to
build healthy soil that can hold onto
more water during during extreme weather
events
so that's the first part of the report
the second part of the report digs into
the ways that we think policy can help
can change to support regenerative
agriculture and scale it up
we analyzed all of our interview
transcripts using a qualitative analysis
software to see what common themes
emerged across the interviews
when it came to the barriers and
opportunities there were four major
pathways for changing agricultural
policy to support more regenerative
agriculture
next slide please
the four pathways are
to level the federal investment playing
field and invest in regenerative
stewardship
invest in decentralized food systems
infrastructure
support farmers and ranchers
and fund regenerative agriculture
research and extension
our interviewees were very clear that
changes needed to happen throughout the
food system which is why our policy
recommendations touch on so many
different issues their experiences show
the need to transform this industry
holistically
now there's a handy one pager on the
website next slide
i'll give you a quick brief look at what
that one pager looks like
um that summarizes all of our policy
recommendations in each of these four
buckets
and i think there's a link provided to
this one pager on the eesi website
now i'm going to dig into the research
and extension bucket and the other
panelists will each discuss the others
next slide please
so research and extension provide
technical resources to growers across
the country and can be administered in a
variety of different through a variety
of different entities including
land-grant colleges extension services
conservation districts and usda programs
now these technical resources are
necessary for disseminating information
like for alerting growers about new
grant programs or changes to existing
grant program guidelines
these technical resources are also
necessary for connecting scientists with
growers
for trialing and experimenting new
management techniques and organizing
field days for growers to connect and
share with each other
we learned that the dearth of region
specific and operation
operation-specific technical resources
is a challenge for the regenerative
movement for example
finding information about practicing
organic no-till in the pacific northwest
was brought up a few times in our
interviews
and this dearth of information
is especially problematic given that one
of the basic principles of regenerative
agriculture is to employ farming
practices that are specific to one's
microclimate and environment remember
that principle understanding your
environmental and social contacts
so we strongly encourage providing
consistent stable and adequate funding
for conservation technical assistance
and conservation districts these
entities that are crucial in providing
technical resources to growers and
meeting growers where they are to
provide those technical resources
next slide
now regenerative growers are innovative
and they are curious
they experiment on their fields to find
the best mix of practices seed types
livestock rotations and soil amendments
for their unique landscape i think i've
mentioned that a few times if you can't
tell already
on-farm research is a key ingredient of
regenerative agriculture so we want to
see robust funding for programs that
encourage experimentation like the
usda's ser sustainable agriculture
research and education program and the
soil health demonstration trial which
was a program established in the 2018
farm bill
now i think that's all i got time to
cover get it cover cover cropping
looking forward to answering your
questions and back to you
awesome thank you so much uh i've looked
through the report and now i can't wait
to go back and look at it again after
that presentation um unfortunately i i'm
hopeful that we don't like like a huge
number of our audience drop off to go
read the report but everybody should go
read the report it's excellent
there aren't as many cover crop puns and
regenerative agriculture puns as i would
like but arohi just helped make up for
that so congratulations again on an
excellent report um i'd like to make uh
like to remind everybody of two things
one is everyone can go um to our website
www.esi.org
if you want to go back and revisit rohit
slides uh and actually download
um
download them for your for your work
please do so everything's available the
same will go for uh our other slides
today uh as well
everything's available online also
there's an opportunity to ask us
questions and you can send us questions
uh via email the email address to use is
ask
eesi.org that's ask esi.org you can also
follow us on twitter
at eesi online
uh our
uh next speaker is
um
dr michael coutwa johnson michael is an
assistant specialist for the school of
natural resources and the environment at
the university of arizona he is also
affiliated with the newly forming
indigenous center resilience center
which will work with tribal communities
on issues related to water energy and
food
michael is also an enrolled member of
the hopi tribe and traditional hopi dry
land farmer
michael welcome to the briefing today
i'm really looking forward to your
presentation
hello thank you very much uh my name is
michael cotisdo with johnson uh sorry i
had to step away for a second but you
know we've been all talking about uh you
know regenerative agriculture and as a
hernia have been she mentioned that you
know this is nothing new to us and this
is the concept we've been practicing at
least in my region for um about 3000
years so when you know when senator
tester says that he's a third generation
farmer he's talking to one that goes
about 250 250 generations back
and so i kind of want to talk about this
um
okay yeah so like i said indeed
did indigenous religions regions of
agriculture is nothing new to us and so
as as a scientist and a phd and
everybody has their own little
terminology i came up with something to
define what indigenous regenerative
agriculture means in the context so go
ahead and start that so um so i have
regenerative agriculture defined
as ira is a process of incorporating
place-based ways of knowing supported by
culture belief systems and
environmentally friendly derived
survival schemes over millennia now it's
important to all understand all that
because if you really look at the
context of the sense it incorporates
everything that was already talked about
uh but by one of our panelists so go
ahead next slide
okay so it's also it's also we also have
to understand why it's why it's so
important so you know indigenous
indigenous people protect 80 of global
biodiversity on a mere 25 of the
planet's land with only less than 5
percent of the world's population now
that's important because when we're
talking regenerative agriculture we're
also talking the biodiversity it's the
biodiversity of our crops
uh that are that are basically place
place regionally based and things like
that that allow them to survive and so
we're looking at an example of what the
biodiversity means it doesn't mean that
that we don't that all the crops don't
come up at the same it's not a monocrop
culture it's a perfectly designed
culture that fits the environment i'm
always wanting to say look at the hopi
reservation you know we grow corn to fit
the environment and we do not manipulate
the environment to fit the corn so go
ahead and go ahead and change that
so when we talk about climate adopted
crops here that's an example of a corn
plant it's kind of bushy like that and
we can people give me a little bit of
brief because they say i'm the
bushmaster
when it comes to farming and stuff like
that but the climate adaptive crops that
we raise out here that our play space
are very important this is a picture
that was taken in july you can see how
cracked the ground is we only we don't
get any rainfall all the way from april
all the way up until july when we do
have our first monsoon rains if you do
have them at all and so you can see how
cracked the ground is but you can see
how beautiful that crop is thriving you
know up and hopefully we've learned to
work the environment in ways that every
single one of our conservation
techniques is designed to conserve soil
moisture when it comes to agricultural
production
so when it comes to human well-being and
i think we kind of touched on that uh
you know
i i kind of could really understand why
we feel like we do when we do what we do
because we're working with our hands
we're working with the environment you
know it's unfortunate last time in the
farm bill in 2018 we had to have
some money set aside for suicide
prevention of that the farm that was
occurring
on farming units
across the united states and so i think
one of the things that prevents us from
doing that at least at hopi is that we
we're experiencing we have experienced
crop failure a number of times you know
and for us this is merely about
subsistence it's merely about
um who we are it's tied directly into
our faith and that's what makes it so
resilient so we plant no matter what you
know so it's very important that we
incorporate human well-being and which
it does you know this those kids right
there they're the next generation that's
coming up to be farmers themselves and
so i like that picture with that said i
kind of wanted to bring in some some
actually on the next slide i wanted to
bring in some of our own recommendations
that follow along with what
with it with what the natural resource
defensive council has put out and so the
first one is
you know to enforce existing legislation
things like the american indian
agricultural resource management act of
1993 which by the way has never received
congressional funding it's just an act
and it should receive congressional
funding because in there there's a
conservation program called arma which
which is the agriculture in agriculture
american american indian agriculture
management acts that would allow us to
basically take over the conservation
program and manage it the way we'd like
to same thing with alternative funding
arrangements it was passed in 2018 but i
have yet to see legislation on that to
actually implement that here in arizona
i think we only have two tribes out of
the 23
that are actually using alternative
funding arrangements and that also opens
the door too because we like to practice
what we like to practice and it's just
recently that the white house passed an
agenda
called itek that actually incorporates
some of our traditional knowledge and
set guidelines to be incorporated into
federal agencies the second one is very
important creating funding mechanisms
through legislation to support locally
led small farmers and regenerative
agricultural initiatives right now
there's really none of that and so what
happens is the regenerative person or
the conventional person has a hard time
getting off because there's a three to
five year window that doesn't cover the
money that he's gonna lose because when
you switch over you're not gonna make
money you're gonna lose money for a
little bit until you're able to up
through the soils and everything else
the second one is fun initiatives geared
towards agricultural related
infrastructure the native american
agricultural fund has a beautiful plan
called reimagining food economies and
basically what that does is that that
lets us have you know establishes
infrastructure for things like meat
processing centers there's only i think
four in the united states so we need
some more of those so i'm just not
trying to only help you know american
indian people but also non-indians as
far as how we're going to
upscale our supply chain and things like
that
and so it also calls for food hose
because one of the the main things that
we had out here at trouble on the
reservation system is that there's no
place to really store food so like at
the open reservation sometimes the saint
mary's food truck would come up and then
we'd wind up half of it would go back
because we did not have a place to store
the food the other thing is to also
support adequate funding for the
federally recognized tribal extension
program that's a big one because you
know not all universities not all land
grant universities have extension agents
on indian reservations this specific
piece of legislation does call for that
it's just not funded adequately enough
and so you can there's a link there you
can turn on to read more about that the
next one is to aid in the development of
permanently funded regionally based or
nationally based native american policy
and technical centers in the united
states for an example the udon center
that's congressionally funded wouldn't
it be nice to have one or two of those
here in the united states the university
of arizona which i happen to work for
has just established the indigenous
resilience center that'd be another
place so we're going to develop policies
right out of that on a regionally based
approach
and use the word tribes you know as far
as the people that are here i think a
lot of times people forget to put that
in there when it comes to legislation so
we need to use the word tribes in
federal legislation so that we're able
to be covered by that because if we
don't do that sometimes the states are
sharp all the funds and we don't get
anything
and so you know i would also encourage
people to look at the native farm bill
coalition some of their agenda because a
lot of their a lot of their
their designs just specifically help
indian country but it's also
specifically to help others especially
in the area of regenerative agriculture
and so with that you know that's pretty
much my whole my whole speech there but
i really want to thank you for letting
me talk
thank you michael for that excellent
presentation and as a reminder uh people
in our folks in our audience can go on
our website www.esi.org
download michael's slides to use them as
a resource for later and um his slides
also include those very helpful links
that he mentioned at the end as well our
next panelist is chris reynolds chris is
midwest regional director for the
american farmland trust midwest
he's a fifth generation corn and soybean
farmer in oh
nokomis illinois i hope i said that
right i somehow managed to get all this
way into the briefing preparation
without learning how to say your your
hometown christmas so sorry about that
who grew up on a diversified grain and
livestock farm he began his soil health
journey in 2013 by incorporating cover
crops no-till and nutrient management
practices into his farming operation and
he continues to expand and improve their
use on his farm each year and chris
you're a returning panelist uh you did a
briefing with us last year on natural
climate solutions if i'm not mistaken so
it's great to have you back looking
forward to your presentation and please
correct how i pronounced her
thank you dan uh
really appreciate it and you did uh you
did pronounce it correctly so
um
so hello and uh thank you everyone for
joining us today we can go ahead and
move to the next slide
um as dan mentioned my name is chris
reynolds and i'm the midwest regional
director for american farmland trust i'm
also a fifth generation steward of the
land on a corn and soybean farm
in central illinois and agriculture and
conservation have been a huge part of my
life
my entire life and and one of the
reasons why i was drawn to come to work
for american farmland trust over five
years ago aft is a national nonprofit
organization and our mission is
protecting farm and ranch land promoting
sound farming practices and keeping
farmers on that land
the photo on the left there is a picture
of my grandfather in the early 1970s
cultivating soybeans with an open
cab
case 930 tractor uh that tractor is
still in the use on the farm today um
but in a much different capacity uh the
photo in the middle is of my youngest
son in a soybean field this photo was
taken several years ago and
this field was one of the first fields
that i no-tilled
into a green uh cereal rye crop
and so it's just exciting to see um you
know as as as i've progressed in my soul
health journey
and also looking at
my children and and some of the
experiences that they've had along the
way as well as i mentioned i began my
soil health journey in in 2013 by
incorporating cover crops into some
existing no-till fields to reduce
erosion suppress weeds and reduce
chemical costs associated with weed
control
since that time i've seen a lot of
different improvements in the soil that
are really making it a lot more
resilient during periods of drought
i also know that i can and and will
continue to try to do better by the soil
and we'll continue to find more ways to
make climate smart conservation
practices work for me
and my farming operation
and as a farmer i'm experiencing you
know increased management challenges
that are resulting from fewer favorable
planting days in the spring
due to more intense and more frequent
rainfall events
um this has really made it more
important than ever to adopt soil health
practices but at the same time it's made
it more challenging
cover crops you know require an
additional level of management they have
to be planted in the fall when harvest
activities are the main priority
and for example because of a wetter than
normal spring this year i had a total of
six planting days that were adequate for
planting
in april and may
in order to get my corn and soybeans
planted so cover crops and no-till often
go hand-in-hand when they're used
together and can really provide multiple
benefits and i just really really love
this slide and how it shows all of these
different benefits in one place you know
we can reduce erosion and winter soil
loss we can keep those deep rooted cover
crops um to help improve nutrient
cycling
um
improves on-farm water quality
we can produce more biomass into that
soil
just a lot of great things that are that
are happening whenever we have these
prac when we're utilizing these
practices on the farm so as a
conservationist an agronomist and a
director for midwest programming i'm
always looking for programs that can
help drive additional conservation
practice adoption across the landscape
this is what led us to explore program
opportunities like the fall covers for
spring savings program in illinois this
program allows for farmers to receive a
crop insurance premium discount for
planning cover crops
with really minimal new capacity demands
on service providers and agencies this
program can act as a bridge to provide
some support while access is lined up
for more substantial technical and
financial assistance
and really so that farmers can try on
cover crops at a size that is right for
them
so many people ask why crop insurance
why
why couple crop insurance and
conservation and it's fairly simple crop
insurance is a trusted safety net
program
it has an established acceptance in the
ag community and because of its
widespread use crop insurance plays a
significant role in shaping decision
making in american agriculture
the federal crop insurance program or as
i'll refer to in this presentation
federal crop or federal crop program
is a critical risk management program
the program is managed by usda's risk
management agency
it operates with the mission to provide
market-based risk management tools to
strengthen the economic stability of ag
producers in rural communities
in 2019 federal crop covered 300 million
acres of crop land which include that it
included the vast majority of corn wheat
and soybean acres
and equaled approximately 90 percent of
all of that crop land being covered
the federal crop program is is a
valuable tool for stabilizing farm
incomes farmers largely utilize any
indemnities to pay off short-term
operating loans
and this also speaks to the importance
of crop insurance and maintaining the ag
financial services industry by making it
more certain that loans will be repaid
studies have also shown that enrollment
in federal crop has a positive
relationship with farm survival
in one study on average farms enrolled
in crop insurance survived seven years
longer than farms that did not
and participation in the program reduced
the probability of farm exit by 70
percent
however federal crop does come with some
of its own risks the expected value of
an insured crop is a major factor in
determining the value of the premium
subsidy and indemnity payment
as a result farmers are incentivized to
increase yield increase revenue in order
to maximize the value of these benefits
this may lead farmers to unintentionally
de-prioritize risk mitigating actions
like the use of cover crops and no-till
which can stabilize yields even under
unfavorable circumstances when farms do
not utilize risk mitigating practices
such as these they can become more
vulnerable to extreme weather events
market fluctuations and more
therefore creating added costs and
demands for the federal crop program to
balance
in this manner while federal crop
mitigates short-term financial risk for
farmers institutions it can promote
activities that lead to long-term
production risks that undermine the
sustainability and long-term resilience
of farming operations
although the program has policies in
place to mitigate moral hazards such as
not offering 100 coverage options
insulating farmers from risk may also
distort those same risk signals which
can for instance
remove incentives for farmers events to
invest in climate adaptation
active risk management requires
understanding how human management
decisions interact with natural systems
to make disasters more or less likely to
happen
this is a consideration that is not
currently embedded within federal crop
within agricultural systems the risk
that results from the interaction
between human decision making and
natural systems is best reflected in
crop production methods
for example prolonged heavy tillage
promotes erosion resulting in a loss of
sole organic matter nutrients
and other
and
and it can also limit the soils water
holding capacity and result in more
flooding and less available water for
plants during drought years ultimately
hurting yields
these issues only become more
challenging under the future climate
scenario federal crop cannot be
insulated from the impacts of climate
change
climate change will make federal crop
more expensive and challenging to manage
without mitigating actions
under a high emission scenario
nasa predicts that corn yields will drop
24 percent in just the next 10 years
a 2017 epa study predicted that even
without factoring in the impacts of
extreme weather events such as
hurricanes and flooding unmitigated
climate change will result in lower
yields by the end of the century for all
major commodities with the exception of
wheat
the same study also predicts overall
commodities to increase up to eight
percent by the end of the century due
primarily to yield reductions
because crop insurance benefits are tied
to yield and revenue outcomes these
impacts on crop yield will pose new
challenges for the administration on
federal crop as the impacts of extreme
weather deepen and become more frequent
one study suggested that increasing
temperatures have been responsible for
nineteen percent of total crop insurance
losses from 1991 to 2017
including 40 percent 47 percent of
losses in 2012
a year of historic drought
usda's economic research service
estimated that these climate impacts
could result in the cost of
federal crop
increasing anywhere from three and a
half to twenty two percent if adaptation
practices are put in place
such as making changes to crop varieties
or crop diversification and management
practices however if adaptation
practices are not put in place the cost
of the federal crop program could
increase anywhere from 10 to 37 percent
federal crop can address these risks by
establishing stronger pathways within
the program promote climate smart
conservation practices that reduce
production risk climate smart practices
protect farm incomes while increasing
on-farm resilience to extreme weather
these pathways can be established by
promoting greater interagency
cooperation within usda to connect
farmers to conservation resources
expanding research and pilot projects
and utilizing tools like additional
premium discounts to lower financial
barriers for farmers to invest in these
practices
the use of climate smart conservation
practices needs to be expanded onto more
acres to have a real impact when it
comes to reducing risk in the ag sector
the current adoption of climate smart
practices is still far too low to result
in meaningful risk mitigation across the
ag landscape
for example fewer than one-third of all
cropland acres utilize no-till or
strip-till practices and less than five
percent
utilize cover crops
by increasing the use of just these two
practices
american farmers have an unparalleled
opportunity to combat climate change
improve water quality and and build on
farm resilience and profitability
this lack of practice adoption can be
attributed to a variety of factors lack
of financial and technical assistance
from state and federal government
agencies to assist producers in
minimizing their own finance when
integrating new methods into their
operations
conservation practices can also yield
direct financial benefits for farmers by
stabilizing yields and lowering input
costs for fuel fertilizer and pest
management
a highly successful example of a premium
discount program is the pandemic cover
crop program which was offered by usda
during the 21 and 22 crop years 12.2
million acres was enrolled in this
program in 2021 and the program reached
all lower 48 states at a cost of around
59.4 million dollars
the program provided a five dollar per
acre discount
that was similar to the discount that
were available in select states
in iowa illinois and indiana
the conservation opportunity and
voluntary environment resilience program
or the cover act would establish the
good steward cover crop program to
provide premium subsidies to producers
who plant qualifying cover crops
the cover act extends the 5 acre
premium subsidy offered by the pandemic
cover crop program and boost technical
and research assistance to help farmers
to reduce production risks while
continuing to access
the federal crop program's financial
safety net
the cover act is fully voluntary it does
not require farmers to plant cover crops
in order to be eligible for crop
insurance
and it complements existing usda
programs while providing an easy access
pathway to support farmers planting
covers
the the act also provides additional
funding for technical assistance to
support outreach effort and it creates a
soil health pilot program to evaluate
how additional premium subsidies can be
offered for other soil health practices
that can reduce risk and comply with the
goals of the federal crop program
please feel free to reach out to me or
my colleague max webster and a special
um a special thanks goes out to max he's
our midwest policy manager and
and thank you so much max for helping us
prepare this information and these
slides
and now i'll turn it back to you dan
thank you
thank you chris for an excellent
presentation
one final reminder if anyone in our
audience would like to go back and
revisit chris's presentation
all of the presentation materials from
today are available on our website at
www.eesi.org
and there's still time to ask questions
we have a few of them coming in which is
great you can send us an email ask
esi.org you can also follow us on
twitter at yes i online and join the
live tweeting
our fourth panelist today is brittany
masters brittany is the ceo and
co-founder of roam free ranch britney is
a visionary leader and first generation
bison rancher she has 12 years of
experience in brand management and is a
western sustainability exchange board
member and officer and a center for a
humane economy advisory council member
brittany welcome to our briefing today
looking forward to hearing your
presentation
okay thanks again dan um thanks for
introducing me and good morning everyone
as dan said
my name is brittany and i'm the ceo of
go roam free
my husband and i run rome free ranch in
hot springs montana
and we are first generation bison
ranchers
running a regenerative meat company
um so like i said you know as first
generation bison ranchers
we really believe that as an industry we
can do better
we believe not only can we do better but
we must do better than what the modern
food system has to offer and so at roam
free we promote an approach to animal
agriculture that restores human health
so that's that we do that through
providing nutrient-dense products
we focus on repairing u.s grasslands and
we do that through regenerative
management
and then we prioritize animal welfare
and we do that above our bottom line
but our origin story actually starts a
long time ago
it starts actually back in the summer of
1989.
this is john's dad here on the left and
my husband john is a little guy there on
the right
and john's dad had just bought two pairs
of very short shorts and a brand new
camcorder
and they were on their annual trip
across the u.s his dad was a military
officer so they moved 18 times in 18
years
and along the way they stopped in
montana to see the wild bison
and it was here that john learned the
history of the american bison he learned
all about their rise and their fall and
how their migration patterns actually
created that fertile topsoil that we
rely on today um he learned how there
used to be over a hundred million bison
roaming across the plains and how they
nearly went extinct to make way for
settlers
but i think the most important story
that john's dad told him was actually
about a montana rancher
and it was a man who rounded up the last
of the wild bison and saved the species
from extinction
he was super inspired by the story and
from that moment on at four years of age
he knew he was going to be a bison
rancher but he had to go to school so
fast forward to 2014
john had graduated from the air force
academy he spent five years of
commitment service and then he was ready
to you know follow his true uh first
passion which was bison um
during that time he spent um in the
military he actually lived on the flight
line
and he did that so he could bank his
housing allowance he ate strictly peanut
butter and jelly to save and up
save up enough money to buy a very small
piece of ground in western montana and
nine bison
um but sadly just two years into his
venture after he had built the ranch and
got the bison built a house john had
listed the ranch for sale
and he just couldn't make make it work
financially he struggled to compete
against the large corporations that
really dominate our food system
and that's when i met john
i will skip all of the sweet mushy parts
about the story but ultimately
he convinced me to marry him and i
convinced him to give the ranch one last
go
we doubled down on everything
i quit my corporate job john
and i sold our house
and his parents mortgaged theirs to give
us a loan to start a new business
and the idea was we would create a
value-added product that we'd sell
direct to market and cut out all of the
middlemen
um in 2017 we launched our very first
product which is bison bites it's a
hundred percent grass-fed and
grass-finished meat snack that also is
sugar-free
and if you go to the next slide
we just recently launched a line of
ready to eat meals that have prepared
sous-vide this is one example this is
our bison chili and our products are now
sold in costco in natural grocers and
over 400 independent retailers across
the u.s
next slide
so while we've seen tremendous support
from our community here locally and
nationwide we've had really strong
demand for our products it it hasn't
come without a significant amount of
challenges and sacrifice
and i don't think our story is unique
you know i think that i know many first
first-generation ranchers and even
generational ranchers that have similar
experiences so i think this our story
helps to illustrate kind of the
struggles that regenerative producers go
through
um john and i we always joke that if i
had known the kind of barriers we'd run
into i would have sold that ranch way
back in 2014
but but all jokes aside the truth is
that
while regenerative agriculture has been
one of the most rewarding experiences of
my life it hasn't been the easiest path
our food system
and the infrastructure that supports it
is really built to benefit these large
multinational corporations that control
the industry
and you know as a small brand if you
manage to keep your head above water
long enough um really the only long-term
success
plan is to sell your business to one of
those larger corporations um to pay off
your inevitable debt that you're sure to
accumulate so
i think as most people know
80 percent
of our industry is owned by just four
large multinational corporations
and they control the infrastructure to
further process livestock
and while animals livestock animals are
born and raised on ranches all across
the u.s
most or the majority are trucked down to
that fertile corn belt for finishing and
processing
um and this just gives the power
the leverage and the value that's
created to those corporations rather
than the rural communities where the
animals are grown
um so to make it roam free as a ranch
has to operate completely outside of the
system
we compete for slaughter slots
from small custom processors
we typically have to commit to those
slots 18 months in advance so we're
making really big bets on our sales
forecast
and we only round up our animals once a
year to for processing we check them
over 16 hours
which is
you know the part that we hate the most
about our job um and then we freeze our
meat and use it throughout the year so
we end up paying very high costs for
cold storage for transportation
especially in this environment and in
addition our slaughter costs cost us
four times more than what our larger
competitors pay
and it's not just the slaughter that's
challenging it's also the further
processing or the value-added portion so
we use a local smokehouse and we learned
recently that they they had to pick up
a contract from one of the largest
turkey brands in order to have just a
consistent
business
and so they had to push out smaller
brands like us you know just to make
room for them
and there just really isn't any capacity
for smoking and curing available right
now as some of these larger brands
continue to get bigger and bigger and
take over more market share
the perfect example of this is just a
few months ago we had to turn down what
would be an estimated one million dollar
purchase order from sprouts
because of the lack of capacity and so
we're working through that trying to
figure out how to you know grow
regionally and and just work with within
the capacity that we have
if you want to go to the next slide
uh so what can be done about the
infrastructure
we feel that um we need to invest
significantly
in regional infrastructure so
you know decentralizing our food system
and giving some of that value back to
the producers on the land so that they
can stay on the land um and this is
really the only way we see regenerative
producers succeeding
um john and i have been trying to
develop actually a mobile processing
unit over the last couple years
we believe it's the most efficient
sustainable and certainly the safest way
to process our animals but we just
haven't been able to get there and i
think first and foremost it's it's
because ranchers like us need affordable
financing
you know leveraging our parents
retirement just isn't going to work
again so
so we need access to that to that cheap
capital um and then secondly
a lot of it is just help with the
regulatory
process and paperwork and getting some
consultation around how to get through
that
you go to the next slide
um and i just want to leave you with
this thought so you know a lot of people
ask
well why invest in new infrastructure
we've got a system in place it's been
working for 100 years why now and i
think it's because honestly we're
running out of time
the american grasslands in america used
to be the most diverse ecosystem that we
had
but industrial agriculture has really
depleted that finite resource and and
changed the landscape that we produced
mostly just five commodities and what
was the most diverse ecosystem in the
world
and we're depleting about 24 billion
metric tons of topsoil each year
globally
so we're tilling that up for mono crops
we're releasing carbon into the
atmosphere at an alarming rate and we've
lost that rich biodiversity that once
created the fertile soil
that leads to a lack of resiliency on a
dependence on foreign chemicals and
other inputs
and some estimates and people argue this
all the time but we know that if we do
nothing we will eventually run out of
topsoil
to the next slide please
but there is a solution so you know it's
right under our feet and it has been
around since the very beginning of time
and that's regenerative agriculture and
that's agriculture that builds top soil
it increases biodiversity it adds
resilience and strengthens rural america
and it offers this abundant diverse rich
food system that actually nourishes the
people it's meant to support
and we just need the infrastructure to
support it so um
that's it the next slide is just my
contact information if anybody has any
questions or wants to discuss things
further i'd love to talk to you and
just thank you so much for your time
thank you brittany for a great
presentation i have a craving now for
bison bites um so
thank you for that um i need to eat
before i do these briefings because now
that bison chili looks so good and it's
said it was sous-vide like you can't go
wrong with that so
have to get some um
we have lots of time for q a and we have
lots of questions coming in from the
audience and we have a couple that we
wanted to talk about uh as well ahead of
time so why don't we go ahead and dig
right in to our questions and answers
and um for people in our audience
there's still time to ask questions so
you can send us an email ask at eesi.org
and also follow us on twitter
or online at esi online on twitter um
but the first question i wanted to get
to and
i think we'll start with you and then
we'll go through the
presentations uh or the order of
presentations
how do we mainstream regenerative
agriculture for someone like me who
doesn't know a lot about being a farmer
or a rancher i just listen to four
presentations and i'm i'm totally
convinced that this is the way to go but
we're not there yet how do we mainstream
these practices at scale
good i'm glad our report worked then
um well the fun thing is we have a whole
report that delves into the different
policy levers we can pull to help make
regenerative agriculture the norm and
help mainstream it through through our
political choices and decisions and
through our policy um and those four
buckets of reform i've talked about
already the other panelists have talked
about already leveling the federal
investment playing field like reforms to
the federal crop insurance program that
chris mentioned
finally getting more robust and more
comprehensive support for farmers and
ranchers and indigenous growers like
what dr johnson mentioned really
focusing on
regionalizing and decentralizing our
food systems infrastructure like
brittany's so you know thoroughly
discussed like these are the ways that
we help
make regenerative agriculture the norm
that the backbone that infrastructure
the policy decisions that can really
help fuel um getting more acres under
regenerative management
now the other thing i would want to i
would want to say here is um
like regenerative agriculture isn't
hypothetical it's not some like oh i
wish this was happening or this sounds
like a really good idea
regenerative agriculture is happening
there are growers who are practicing who
are using this management philosophy
already and i think what will help
mainstream this movement is to point out
to the shine shine the light on these
incredible leaders of of the
regenerative movement the folks who are
doing this work in every single state um
learning from them
getting their ideas for how to engage
with consumers with policy makers at the
local state or federal level bringing in
indigenous communities and other
historically underserved communities to
the decision-making table i mean the
fact that we're having this briefing the
fact that we're having this conversation
is a step in the right direction and i'm
excited for more opportunities
to
shine a light on the leaders like the
three farmers represented on this panel
today
michael love to hear your thoughts about
how we can mainstream these practices
well you know i think a lot of it has to
do with the way our market system set up
right now of the usda market system the
market formula because right now we're
based based upon everything off of
efficiency and quantity so because we
have efficiency and quantity we're
having to use these different types of
inputs that aren't very environmentally
friendly like pesticides herbicides and
everything and so uh in order to
re redo that we need to go back to one
of which would be based on quality like
what kind of quality goods are coming
out we all know that plant-based derived
and degenerative agriculture have high
quality in the stuff we have
you know when you even look at you know
cattle grass-fed cattle their nutrient
value is a lot better than the lot dead
cattle just because of the things
they're eating it's all plant-based
buffalo especially buffalo probably the
number one food source that we that we
eat out there but we don't subsidize
enough because there's always some sort
of uh
you know arguments between the cattle
and buffalo as far as what's better for
the what's better for whatever
uh as far as that you know uh we talked
about regionally you know regionally
based um processing centers like the
native american other cultural fund
supports you know i'm i'm also a fan of
mobile things uh mobile processing
centers that was mentioned but the
problem with that is that we don't have
the usda inspectors to go out and do
that so it makes it very difficult to
remove that and so if you look at the
qua operation oklahoma uh you can see
that they're training those on the
tribal lands or training those people at
their at their slaughtering house to be
inspectors
and so you know it's kind of a it's kind
of putting it all together
so but i think the real big problem like
i said is has to do with the efficient
efficiency and quantity argument that
usda offers you know it wasn't too long
ago that you know corn had a nutrient
value into that now the only thing that
has a nutrient value to that is kind of
like cattle and so when we start putting
you know animals above human beings as
far as what we're eating then we come up
with all these different types of uh
diseases that are out there heart
disease cancer everything else so uh we
need to heal our society we need to heal
our heal the land that we're that we're
that work that we're farming on or
producing on so that's basically how i
would streamline that is just change the
formula around so that you're able to
support more small farms because we all
know that small farms have a lot better
quality
in their food
than the big and the big corporations do
and so that's about it thanks chris love
to hear from you and then also brittany
love to hear um your perspective as a
rancher
yeah thanks dan i think you know as
senator turner mentioned in his opening
you know there's as many ways to farm as
there are farmers i think we we also
have to recognize that um every farmer's
in a different place um and and doing
different practices as i mentioned in my
opening um you know there are still a
lot of improvements that i need to make
in my farming operation
and i recognize that there are there are
um
there are challenges that come along
with that but also that i can do better
by the soil so i think if we want to see
regenerative agriculture become more
mainstream we have to we have to be make
it become more commonplace
we have to recognize that the farmers
want to do better by the soul but don't
often have the technical and financial
resources available at that local level
to
to be able to adopt and these new
practices so i think it's a journey i
think you know farmers have to start
adopting some practices
that lead them to the regenerative ag
system
and brittany from your perspective
as a
one of the newer regenerative
agriculture or one of the new newer
adopters of regenerative agriculture on
the panel how can we make this more
common
um you know
i think about it from our products
perspective so you know as a customer
i'm gonna go to go to costco and on the
shelf you know probably the regenerative
products or the grass-fed products are
twice as expensive three times as
expensive and at the end of the day
as producers we're not we're not really
paid more for doing regenerative
agriculture and where the biggest um
the biggest bucket of money is going is
in that isn't that further processing
and so when you know are we
we have to be price competitive uh from
a consumer's perspective and if it's
going to go mainstream and if our of our
processing is costing four times more
than conventional agriculture it's going
to be very hard to
to shore up that gap um
and then you know just like michael said
it the
you know the focus the farm bill has a
big nutrition component and the focus
has always been you know how do we
produce as many calories as possible
it's always calorie focused rather than
nutrient density focused and so if
eventually our food is completely devoid
of
nutrients because we don't have
microorganisms because we don't have
biodiversity
then we may be producing more and more
calories and getting you know sicker and
sicker because we don't have the
nutrients in our food that we used to
and so i think you know that's a big
component of how we we um
the nutrition part of the farm bill is
where we can add into a focus on
regenerative nutrient-dense food
great
um i'm going to ask this next question
this one comes to us from our audience
and i think it's actually a good
follow-up to this first question
one of your slides you had 16 boxes and
you had different regenerative
agriculture practices
this question comes to us from our
audience
asking us
so which of those practices are most
commonly used
and do we have any ideas of overall how
many farmers or ranchers are using
these practices
is it is it millions of farmers is it
thousands of farmers but which are the
ones that are most common and
i'm happy to start with you rohit but
i'm eager to hear others thoughts as
well we'll open this up to the group
after you go
yeah um like i mentioned in the
presentation regenerative agriculture
looks pretty looks very different
depending on where you are a
regenerative grower in the pacific
northwest is going to have a different
farming system or farming style than
someone from maine and somewhere from
texas than someone from iowa um but the
the five the five principles that i
shared do there are some common
practices that help
um address all five principles kind of
at once
cover cropping was mentioned a lot um
no-till or low-till was mentioned a lot
focusing on diversification crop
diversification planting perennial crops
to help build um soil organic matter
um agroforestry was mentioned um as a
practice trying to think of what else
crop rotations i mean there were some
common
practices but the the beauty of
regenerative agriculture was like what
chris was saying there's always a chance
to be better and so depending on where
we caught people on their regenerative
journey they were using a different
suite of practices
and michael chris brittany please feel
free to jump in if you have any
additional commentary about
what are some of the more common
practices and how widely
um i i can really just speak to animal
agriculture um and the most common
practices that i see in in my area um i
mean you know
people always usually start with the
practices rather than the holistic view
of what is regenerative agriculture and
so most people when they when they hear
that they think of rotational grazing
and so that's really the idea is you're
you know not return you're grazing down
a particular pasture and then not
returning to that pasture for at least
12 months afterwards to let it rest
um and that looks very different whether
it's so you're moving your animals every
day or you're moving your animals every
seven days or every month
and it depends again you know so many
factors go into what practices you're
going to use i think that's probably the
most common one and i think it's the one
that you can't do a lot of the other
things until you've
you've got that figured out because you
need your pasture arrangements before
you can start really moving around water
or or planting or anything else
and you know as far as
how many people are doing that that's a
great question i don't know the answer
um i can tell you in my community
that um i'm i'm actually on the flathead
reservation here in western montana
and we
you know i haven't
neighbors that would say they're
conventional conventional conventional
you know growers um and they're all
doing a little bit of regenerative
agriculture here and there without
calling it that
um but true like high intensity where
you're where you're moving your animals
every day that's pretty rare around here
um but they maybe may be doing just one
or two tenants of what we would consider
regenerative
yeah dan i think you know when we look
at you know the soil really wants and
needs to have plants growing on it in it
you know year round and so when we can
go from having a crop growing five or
six months out of the year to 11 or 12
months out of the year a plant growing
not even necessarily a crop
i think that's what's really most
important
you know within regenerative agriculture
and getting more diverse crop rotations
on the land and then finally you know
finishing that up with
with the livestock component you know
it's really it's a systems approach but
uh i think you have to start with
making sure there's always a living root
in that soil
michael happy to give you uh opportunity
to weigh in too on which of these
practices
i'm just i'm just thinking because you
know my panelists were talking on such a
big scale you know i mean our our farms
out there average one to two acres and
there's a reason for that because you
know it's play space designed if we were
to go any bigger than that we'd have
blow blowouts because of the wind
erosion and stuff that we have out there
but you know just when i look at my own
cropping system from uh from a technical
standpoint of doing put a little science
behind it you know our roles out there
it's not rare would call economically
valuable i can't take a hopi cornfield
and put in iowa and expect them to adopt
that and and to make money off of that
and so you know our students assistant
is based upon just our survival our
cultural survival and who we are at hopi
and so you know our roles facing it hope
you for example is you have like six
feet between rows you know you'll have
clusters of plants you'll have planting
depths anywhere from six to eighteen
inches
you know and i like to see corn anywhere
in the in in the united states come up
from that depth you know we only receive
six to ten inches of annual rainfall a
year can you imagine that growing corn
when i was at cornell they told me three
three inches of annual rainfall a year
and i said we agronomy has something
else to learn here a little bit
and so you know it's that type of
approach but you know for us it's just
place based you know and so it's it's
our faith in our that makes our crafting
system so resilient three thousand years
of doing this method so the replication
is very
important also if it works you know
don't change it too much but uh we're
able to do that and so but anyways
that's kind of my approach on that
probably didn't answer the question um i
don't know how many people are still
doing that that'd be interesting study
to know as far as how many people are
actually doing regenerative agriculture
and things like that but yeah so thanks
the usda the usda has its census every
five years and they capture
some data on cover crops on conservation
no-till but i think there's a lot of
room for improvement on the types of
questions and data that are collected
through that census to better address
this this question of how many folks are
using these practices
i was thinking that what britney said is
probably the case where people are doing
it even if they're not calling it so
probably a little more widespread at
least at some level
um chris i think perhaps we'll start
with you on this next question and then
we'll go uh we'll open it up to other
panelists
something you talked about in your
presentation there are some things the
federal government does
policy-wise that might make it easier or
harder
to be a regenerative farmer or rancher
what are the ways or what are some
additional ways that federal farm policy
could be more supportive or more
encouraging of regenerative agriculture
and are there things the federal
government does right now that makes it
harder to be a regenerative farmer or
rancher
yeah thanks thanks dan so i think one of
the things that can be improved is to
prioritize
soil health planning and regenerative ag
planning you know through the federal
programs you know there's a lot of a lot
of focus on the practices themselves but
i think you know providing farmers with
that technical assistance and ultimately
financial assistance
and some incentives to
be on that soil health journey or that
regenerative ag journey you know start
out you know with cover crops and start
you know with no-till and start
incorporating other regenerative ag
practices into that farming operation
and so i think there's a real need to to
to prioritize you know planning from an
entire farm system
at the field scale
you know i think there's a lot of a lot
of you know great things happening
within the system
um
i think there's also a lot of room for
improvements you know i think that local
led approach is is something that we we
cannot lose sight of we have to remember
that
you know every place is different not
just in in a particular state but
every watershed is different every
county is different every community is
different so
you know recognizing that um support is
needed at that local level is is really
crucial
michael arroyo brittany love to hear you
know
well i'm kind of i'm kind of geared
towards her sort of it was just her but
you know it to me you know we subsidize
so much for for big farms we need to
have some sort of formula that
subsidizes smaller ones
because it really it really you know
some of the studies show that there's a
three to five year gap funding gap when
you're switching over from conventional
to agriculture you know in the farmer
american farmer you know i'm not i'm not
going to be you know or against
conventional agriculture but that person
really has no choice because the system
hasn't trapped you know that person has
to you know has to do that because of
because of the quality and
efficiency that art that i made earlier
and so uh but you know things like this
that we always that we always tend to
forget we have these discussions that we
need to also try to figure out to create
incentives for our youth to be involved
you know our youth to be involved it'd
be my my blessing if i were to take
hopeicorn and give everybody one colonel
and all the kids in the united states
and have give them a cup and have them
grow a corn plant out of that
you know that that kind of thing and
showing why it's important because we
can all talk about that's the other
thing we can all talk about regenerative
agriculture we can all do regenerative
agriculture but we really need to
understand the principles of why we need
to do this
you know it's like it hope you know we
can all plan out there but unless our
youth know why they're planting it just
becomes another commodity another way of
doing things and so we have to
incentivize our young people to do this
and that means also involving some of
these big meetings that we have you know
because i think the youth are our future
right i mean i was lucky to have 42 of
our of our k through 5 5th graders come
and visit my little farm out there
recently
and so there's nothing better than
watching a little kid just get happy and
you know you can tell little kids you
know like
my way of teaching is like you know you
can go out there and be complaining well
you can be a hydrologist you can be a
botanist you can because we do
everything when it comes to holistic
management of agriculture that's what we
do we incentivize that we incentivize it
based upon our own culture and what they
what they should learn in the future and
what keeps them hoping you know and so
but that could be passed along everybody
it's just like your grandfather talking
to you and talking about how important
farming is and things like that so
just at a little different level there
but that's how kind of how i kind of
understand that and federal programs are
geared right now towards corporations
and everything else we need to put it
right back to where it belongs right
locally lit that's been talked about
here a number of times we can do that
you know we also understand as consumers
we need to think about the crops and
stuff that we're buying because
consumers what you buy makes makes the
wheel run right and so we need to think
about that a little bit more so yeah
that's about it
yeah i'd love to i look back on um on
that because
you said something about the youth and
that like is just so close to um to my
heart because obviously as first
generation ranchers and somebody trying
to get into this industry it's it's
certainly been a challenge and i get
asked that question a lot is like okay
so how do we get the next generation
involved
and the average rancher i think is 65
years old and doesn't have any intention
of passing the land off he'd rather sell
it and retire in fiji than you know
continue to labor on and um
you know the the barrier that we always
run into is the access to secure land to
land that we know if we start putting in
a bunch of infrastructure and a bunch of
hard work sweat and tears that it's
going to be around um you know 7 15 you
know years um and so
you know when i think about what kind of
policies
maybe um
harm that you know the the re in the
conservation bucket of the farm bill
there's these retired lands um there's
also just a bunch of land that that is
used that's owned uh by the government
and is used for conventional farming and
ranching
and i think it'd be you know really
interesting to look at what what if we
use some of those retired lands or
incentivized um wealthy land owners
instead to give you know favorable
leases or subsidized leases to beginning
farmers and ranchers because
getting into ranching is nearly
impossible if you have to pay mortgage
on bear land um you know you need 40
down on bear land and there's just no
way in my lifetime that i could afford
the cost of land to pay for that
operation um
using animals and so
we've had to be really creative about
how we grow and that's always been
through through land leases and with
bison that's a whole new challenge which
i don't have to dive into but
essentially i can only you know go
work with private land owners and the
infrastructure needed to
support bison is
much different than it is for cattle so
um just making you know access to
this land and finding creative solutions
to get the younger generation involved
because many times they don't have land
already
yeah um
i like the question because i think what
you're learning from the other panelists
is that this the ways that federal
policy
currently discourages regenerative
agriculture if flipped can encourage
regenerative agriculture um i'm thinking
of you know chris mentioned alfred
mentioned this um the federal crop
insurance program right the way that our
current
subsidy regime favors
um farms that
degrade soil health or that are not
practicing regenerative agriculture um
the federal crop insurance program
covers 90
of the u.s the united states's cropland
which means it has enormous potential
and influence over
agricultural the agricultural landscape
and agricultural policy
so i'm thinking about you know if we can
shift those farm subsidies um shift the
federal crop insurance program so that
the money that's currently being spent
on it chris what did you say like 77.9
billion or something like that over the
next 10 years if we can change the way
that the crop insurance program
currently works to
encouraging soil health and regenerative
agriculture to rewarding growers for
adopting a more regenerative mindset i
mean that's
that seems like a win-win-win
great thanks for that that's really
interesting um and i think you were the
one who said it in your presentation all
of this stuff works together it works
better when it works together so
appreciate that answer
um michael i'd like to ask you might
steal that little quick i like that
you're still whatever absolutely um
what matters is more regenerative
agriculture so whatever it takes um
michael i'd like to start with you for
this next question um
uh you mentioned sort of how long
your
family has been on the land it's kind of
amazing and so i'm kind of hopeful that
you have sort of a long-term perspective
on this how do climate impacts like
shifting seasons extreme heat drought
how do those climate impacts affect
regenerative agriculture differently
than maybe industrial agriculture
well the climate impacts to me would be
less severe on regenerative agriculture
if and only if the crops that they're
raising are biodiverse
you know um that that's that's the big
thing you know unfortunately uh we're
not moving we have not been moving that
way for the last 50 or so years we've
been always mono cropping and so when
you have one thing that hurts it you
know like for example like drought or
too much water
you wind up wiping up that whole crop so
there's no diversification whereas hopi
you know
we they're all the whole things that are
biodiverse it's not even corn it's not a
monocrop it comes up at different times
different years uh things like that it
sometimes doesn't look palatable but you
know
it's at least we know what we're eating
you know i think that's the important
thing
and so uh but with the climate
fluctuations you can see you know that
things are getting smaller and so i'm a
person who talks about biodiversity is
to try to raise something every year
we're able to look at through our
knowledge just look at just the the
different biology the bio of logical
indicators like the different types of
plants to figure out we're going to have
a drought or not but regardless of what
we see we plan anyway because you know i
i i like seed banks and stuff like that
but i guarantee that if you take a seat
that's been sitting in a sea bank for
100 years if you try growing in today's
climate it's not going to do well
and so we need to think about that so
the biodiversity that we have things
that you have you know when you look at
cattle if you i mean the bison when you
look at their range and how they raise
their range and you look at all the
ecological stuff that's under there it's
it's very it's very good for the
environment you know very good for that
and so uh but i really think the
biodiversity crops needs to be pushed
forward further you know and and where
those biodiversity is gonna come from
they're just going to come from
indigenous people i know that and so we
need to also have laws and rules and
regulations in our in our books set up
data centers that i believe that would
help us preserve some of that because if
you look at corn billion dollar industry
where did that come from you know it
came from indigenous people originally
and so uh we have the diverse crops we
have them we have the seeds available
it's just a matter of how we're able to
use those not really protect that but
also create deterrence uh that would
allow us to keep moving because if you
really look at that we're holding 80
percent of biodiversity so listen to
this people we need to support
indigenous locally led efforts small
grassroot efforts who are still doing
this because if not we're going to lose
that and once we lose that without true
biodiversity we have no real
sustainability
and so just think about that one but
that's how i answer that question but
thanks
hmm interesting chris love to hear from
you what are your thoughts on sort of
how these how climate impacts might
affect regenerative agriculture
differently than industrial agriculture
well i certainly think that regenerative
agriculture is going to be more
resilient
it's going to be able to weather the
storm no pun intended
you know through through climate changes
climate impacts
but as i mentioned in my opening you
know it doesn't come up without
challenges as well you know it's still
you know fewer favorable planting days
and just
changing in the seasons it makes it
a lot more challenging to to plant
multiple crops in a year to to get
planting done in a timely manner to to
get harvest done in a timely manner so i
think we continue to have to adapt and
and and learn from from what's working
and what isn't and and i think you know
as michael mentioned the the crop
diversification
is such a big piece to this so we have
to figure out how we can develop new
markets for crops
uh that can be grown you know on a on a
larger scale
brittany are he interested in your
thoughts as well
yeah i mean so we've definitely been
able to withstand you know we've had
terrible droughts the last few years as
senator tester mentioned
and while we've been able on our ranch
to get by with the forage that we that
we have because we're building more
forage every year
there's downstream impacts so what
happened was
a lot of people couldn't afford to buy
the hay to feed their animals so
slaughter houses got backed up so
everybody was sending their animals to
processing otherwise they were just
simply going to starve on on the ranch
and so
then
you know the bottleneck became
processing um
which we're finally getting through now
but because people were basically
slaughtering their replacement heifers
and their replacement livestock now
there's a shortage of animals on the
market
and so there's all these unintended
consequences down you know downstream
that just because we're a regenerative
ranch we're not um you know we're not
protected by that by any means and so
the infrastructure really is is such a
big deal to have more capacity um so
that we don't get you know jammed up
like like we are right now
i think the three panelists nailed it um
we had there's one interviewee that that
sticks out in my mind who said something
really profound for me
and she said that healthy soil is their
insurance policy against risk and
climate change and so i think about that
quite a lot when
asked this question about regenerative
ag's potential to
um be more resilient to climate change
than others i mean the fact that healthy
soil holds onto
more water than unhealthy soil is a
direct
resilient a measure of resilience for
those extreme weather events for those
drought events
um
so yeah i and and what dr johnson said
about diversification came up really
frequently in our interviews that they
by adopting crop diversity by build
stacking these enterprises like what
brittany mentioned um on their
regenerative operation they were better
able to withstand
external market volatilities because
they had these different income streams
from a bunch of different products and
value-added products on top of that
well that leads me to sort of i think we
have time for maybe one last one and
brittany probably makes sense to direct
this one to you first i'm curious about
the idea of developing markets for
products that come out of regenerative
agriculture and you talked a little bit
about the consumer's perspective
and i would love to hear brittany and
then we'll we can go through the rest of
the panel maybe some final thoughts on
you know how we create demand uh and
markets for
um things like bison bites
yeah
yeah i mean you know so
we
we created a product to save the ranch
that's the true story um you know i i've
always had a passion for nutrition and
for food um if john had it his weight we
would just be raising animals and we
wouldn't have to deal with all the other
parts of the business but it's it's um
it's sort of um
it works together when you're out there
talking to customers when you're
promoting your product when you have a
brand when you have a customer
facing product and you can reach them
you just have more ability to
to support the ranch and and the the um
entities that are closest to the
customer end up being the ones who
receive the most value from the value
stream so whereas traditionally um you
know it's those branded programs or it's
the big multinational corporations that
own the shelf space if you can get in
and actually have access to that
customer which of course you know um you
know the internet and
amazon and everything has given us more
access to them you can you can start to
extract more of the value
from every animal you produce or every
crop you know you raise and so um but it
but it's not easy right i mean i've i've
spent before this ten years in brand
marketing developing products and brands
and and working on it and so i think
it's it is a
it's a tool that we have
and i think you know the value added
producer grant
is is fabulous at helping producers come
out with a product but i don't think
it's the solution for everyone i don't
think
that it's realistic to ask producers
that are already running a full-time
you know 80 hour per week job to say and
can you just maybe add a product to the
to the list um i think it's it's right
for some ranches but but certainly it's
um beyond the expectation for everyone
and other panelists
thoughts final thoughts on sort of how
we create markets for products that come
from regenerative agriculture
well to me it's really about telling
stories you know for indian people you
know
we just need to tell stories about the
good things we're doing out there but
when it comes to things like i've seen i
know a person in italy's bill of
software so when you has a code on it
just like you know with our phones we
look at the code and that takes you to a
story of how that product was developed
now wouldn't that be something if you
had you know like a buffalo product and
you've seen how that that thing was
raised what it looked like you know the
buy-in would be overwhelming as far as
i'm concerned not just to do that
and then but i don't know if that's
possible but anyways i thought that'd be
a good thing to do uh just putting the
story the value-addedness i think is
also important because uh the supply
chain people have control over that you
know this 100 bushel acres still a
hundred dollar bush in lakewood from 30
years ago from understand you know so
the the person has minimal amount of
room to to do that as far as the
producer is concerned and so value-added
needs to be important now when you but
if you do have these codes on there that
show where these which products are
formed what do you think people are
going to buy you know but we also
remember to make those more accessible
there is no whole foods or no you know
these these these upscale uh grocery
stores on indian reservations at all and
so we need to figure out a way to bring
equity as we do this so as we're as our
as we're also you know put the market
out there we also remember you know how
to create equity at the same time so
that's how i would kind of do that it's
just how the story of regenerative and
what it's about there's just not enough
uh publicity on that and so i think we
should increase the publicity so yeah
chris and then we can give aruhi you can
have the last word today but chris final
thoughts on market development
yeah i think it's uh you know it's a
huge challenge especially you know
looking you know
here in the midwest where there's
millions of acres of uh you know
commodity crops being grown and and just
trying to trying to build that um you
know consumer demand
um but there's just there's so many
acres that um that are ripe for more
crop diversification
um but but farmers have to have a place
to to market that crop and um you know
we've seen
you know a huge shift in all of the
infrastructure that's that's here that's
supporting those crops that we're
growing today and so it's it's it's
going to take a lot to change that
okay now i'll
end with this um so one of my favorite
quotes from wendell berry is eating is
an agricultural act
and to me that is a call to action both
from the grass tops level and the
grassroots level everyone eats
everyone can participate in changing the
food system
from the grass top side the way i see
markets working is through policy
thinking about procurement changes in
procurement policies and procurement
guidelines we have a whole section about
that in our report but from the
grassroots side on the consumer side dr
johnson is totally correct i love this
anecdote of telling stories of
getting consumers to feel connected and
bought in with the folks who are growing
the food that they eat and raising their
kids on um
consumers can vote very loudly with
their dollars
based on what they purchase and so i
encourage folks you know ask questions
about soil health about regenerative
agriculture at farmers markets like who
are you buying from at grocery stores at
restaurants and even have these
conversations with family members or
with for the hill staff on the line with
your bosses um so that's how that's how
i see markets developing for
regenerative agriculture
awesome well thank you so much
thank you to our four panelists today
for
a really really interesting
conversation about pathways to
regenerative agriculture
aruhi michael chris and brittany it was
real pleasure to meet you um putting
this briefing together i hope i'm sure
everyone in our audience learned a lot
about these practices
also like to say special thanks to
senator tester for joining us at the top
of the session
thanks to him and his staff for his
participation today means a lot to have
senator tester participate with us
one final time congratulations to nrdc
on the report it's fabulous everyone
should take a moment to look at it
it's aesthetically pleasing it's an it's
an interesting read it's organized
smartly it's easy to use everyone should
be checking this out
you can find a link to it on the
briefing webpage at www.esi.org
can also find briefing materials
presentation materials excuse me
archived webcast eventually we'll have
some summary notes up there in the next
week or two so everyone can go back and
revisit this briefing i think it's going
to be a big topic as we start thinking
about the 2023 farm bill also like to
say a special shout out to matthew
kaplan at nrdc for his friendly
collaboration uh along uh the process of
putting this briefing together
also like to say special thanks to our
good friend troy hanford for all of his
help putting today's briefing together
as well i'd like to thank my esi
colleagues dan o'brien omri
emma allison anna and savannah and i
even got a special shout out along with
matthew from senator tester so that's
cool thanks to them for putting all of
their hard work into a really
interesting session today
um my colleague will put a oh finally we
have four wonderful summer interns and
they are very active in briefing uh
briefings especially on the day of
live tweeting the questions from the
audience so thanks to christina
stephanie abby and nathan for all their
hard work my colleague is going to put
up a slide
with a survey link
if everyone in our audience today just
has two minutes to take our survey we
read every response um
did you have any issues with the video
with the audio
with the ideas for future
sessions
any feedback we really appreciate it and
like i said we read every response so it
means a lot when you take a moment to
fill out that survey
we're a few minutes over sorry for that
but i think it was well worth it to
spend a little bit of extra time talking
with our panelists today hope to see
everybody back on june 24th for
um let's see what is june 24th
june 24th is where is it uh extreme heat
gonna be a good one uh and june 29
offshore wind energy so the final two
briefings in our living with climate
change and scaling up innovation to
drive down emissions thanks to our
panelists thanks to nrdc and thanks to
our audience for joining us today we'll
sign off there